[Applause]
this is our hand-picked guide for your
weekend
and it's national cookie day so we're
cooking it off with cookies no that
doesn't make sense but you know what i
mean
okay to eat try good vibes cooking
company
it's a little piece of art designed for
your
mouth made by an artist in california
and each cookie is inspired by
crystals and they make a great gift so
you can give someone a rose quartz
cookie for
love and harmony or a tiger's eye cookie
for inspiration
and great news no actual crystals were
harmed in the making of these cookies
and no one has to break a tooth
it's also on our small business gift
guide actually this company
plus we're bringing joni the owner of
good vibes cooking company on the show
next week jody
and we'll learn even more about these
geot
designed beautiful cookies a lot of my
girlfriends are calling me about these
and being like i think these are really
cool
and you know what i have to say jody you
did something different and that is hard
to do
okay next to read
little weird i sat down with this
hilarious
writer jenny slate and i gushed about
her
and i have to tell you i read a lot of
books for this show
which keeps my mind very sharp and this
one
was like being inside of a casserole
full of rose petals and uniqueness
and i highly recommend the story nice
things to do
for tipping yourself toward gentleness
and simple joy it's on page 90.
i started with that and it was my entry
point
this is a phenomenal book to watch
the undoing on hbo now i know everyone's
already into this
so but we're not late to the party the
season finale literally just came out
and this show is so good
it is david e kelly who does big little
lies all the way back to
oh my god he's done everything he's like
the king of television married to
michelle pfeiffer by the way
and um nicole kidman and hugh grant
are i some of the best work i've ever
gotten to see hugh grant do
and i was lucky enough to be in a movie
with him called music and lyrics
and he is bringing his a game i don't
really see him like this very often it
is so striking the performances are
extraordinary
and if you're ever feeling bad about
your life watch this show it'll make you
feel better
um it's also just so good and scary and
creepy and like
the undoing you'll be undone
[Applause]
to download scrabble go i am full on
upset oh yeah by the way i'm playing
like nine games simultaneously
with ember robin britt tom like you name
it i'm
in i love this app
i love playing scrabble and this just
makes it so easy and fun
and i have to say during covid this is a
great way to feel connected with people
it is we need this and it keeps your
mind sharp and it keeps you connected
and it's just fun so i won
the game with tom green last time but i
don't i don't know if i'm gonna win this
one i got
crappy letters and finally a
recommendation from drew's little yellow
book
it's my collection of favorite products
all available on our website so
to buy cbs's manuka honey bandages
i'm telling you these are a game changer
so you know where that little white
patch is normally that's just not the
sticky part that goes on the wound
well in this it's a patch of manuka
honey
and when you take the bandage off you
will see your wound is actually
much more healed far quicker i'm telling
you
you will not go back to another brand
so check out the manuka honey bandages
they are a real game changer
made by cvs so you can check out all
these entries and more in the little
yellow book
that was the weekender go have a good
one
[Music]